okay let's get into audience questions
for the week first question one that
came up indirectly a lot of times
throughout stories we talked about this
week is there anything
at this point that convinced that would
convince trumpists that donald trump
actually lost
we are more than six months out there's
a so-called election audit
happening in arizona they're looking for
bamboo fibers
as evidence that the ballots were dumped
from china uh it's crazy what's going on
so the question is a different one now
six months out than it was six months
ago
six months ago we could have accurately
said um
after these various efforts failed to
demonstrate that there was
fraud as donald trump says some of these
trumpists will become
convinced they will accept that donald
trump really did lose and some did
the percentage of republicans that
believe trump won has declined
over the last couple of months but it's
still really really high
and at this point i don't believe
there is anything that would convince
these trumpets that donald trump
really just lost it wasn't stolen it
wasn't an illegitimate win by joe biden
or whatever
he just lost and there's two things that
are going on
number one at this point you know we
think of the holy grail of the maya
culpa which would be trump coming to
them and saying
sirs i lost that's it
even if he were to do that they still
wouldn't believe it
they would say they would do what's
called special pleading they would say
well
trump says he lost now but because he's
been forced
to say it the deep state or joe biden
threatened him with house arrest or
they got to him and it's not even you we
can't even believe donald trump when he
says this at this point in time that's
one possibility
now if you believe trump to be
the epitome of the alpha male the idea
that
he would be successfully blackmailed
by someone as weak as they see joe biden
being
that also doesn't make sense but
remember none of this makes sense so i
think
even if trump said i was wrong i lost
they those who still believe trump uh
actually won
would just say clearly somebody forced
trump to do that number two
we don't really even need to
theorize or speculate because
for a year trump said the virus isn't
serious
and we're winning and it's like the flu
and we don't need to worry about
anything
and it developed this huge anti-vaccine
sentiment on the right and then trump
was secretly
vaccinated in january at the white house
didn't tell anybody until he was asked
about it months later
and said yeah people people should get
it and
republicans are still the most
anti-covet vaccine group
out there it was too late after
feeding them the misinformation for
months and months really over a year
about the virus
by the time time trump simply said yeah
i got the vaccine and people should get
it
it was too late to even convince them so
once an idea has
spread virally in the minds of these
trumpists even trump himself can't
change their minds that's how powerful
these
uh viral memes of disinformation have
become now
last thing earlier in the week i talked
about anecdotal
thinking a lot of the
uh many of these trumpists believe biden
didn't really win he's lot not
legitimate
and these types of things because of the
things that donald trump said
for so long but there are other
trumpists
who aren't able to get beyond anecdotal
thinking and what i mean by that is
even though we can go and say okay trump
got lots of vote votes but joe
so did joe biden and it was just record
turnout and
we understand why it makes sense
pandemic and one of the
biggest um sort of adjudications of a of
a
white house presidential term and who
knows how long
makes sense there would be a lot of
votes for a lot of these people it's
just anecdotal thinking
like i live in wherever mississippi
everybody i know voted for trump i don't
know anybody who voted for joe biden now
maybe you do but they're scared to
mention it because you're nuts
and they they worry how you would react
but i don't know the people around me
and my
deeply conservative enclave all um all
voted for trump
and i went to a trump rally and it was
filled with trump people and
i watched fox news and they went to a
diner and everybody at the diner seemed
to like trump
my anecdotal thinking is uh informing
and superseding
my views uh superseding the
the empirical broad strokes views of
polling and the fact that you don't hear
from most people on twitter you know no
no one place is going to tell you
sort of what the sentiment is of a
country with 331 million people so
that's another piece of it
and then there's people who are just
every combination of the above or bad
faith actors or
just suffering from a cognitive issue so
no sadly at this point in time
if you still believe that donald trump
actually won i don't believe there's
anything left that could convince you
other
than just time over time maybe some of
these people will be
able to re-examine their beliefs about
the 2020 election
with some distance and objectivity
but beyond that i don't have high hopes
that we're going to convince
these people nor do i think that we
should be employing a retail strategy
of arguing with individuals to try to do
it i think the way to win elections is
let's get turnout up let's prevent voter
suppression rather than arguing with
individual trumpists